hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and today special treat our guest
is also sean carroll but not because
it's a solo episode not because i'm the
only one talking we have another sean
carroll here today on the podcast this
is sean
b carroll and honest to goodness another
person with the same name as me
different middle initial who is a world
famous biologist
who would have thought there's a lot of
strong carols out there as it turns out
i first heard of uh the other sean
carroll when i was a graduate student i
was walking down
uh the road in harvard square and i
stopped at the
out-of-town news newsstand because i saw
that i think it was time magazine had a
story about like the
30 scientists under 30 years old or
something like that who are going to
change the world
and so of course out of as a joke
i opened it up looking for myself now i
knew perfectly well i was not on that
list you don't get on
those lists without being told but also
in no sense that i deserve to be on that
list as a graduate student
uh but to my surprise there i found my
name
and i realized that oh my goodness
there's another person with my name
but the podcast is not going to be a
whole bunch of jokes about us having the
same name
sean carroll the biologist is actually a
leading figure
in the field of evo devo the idea that
evolution is coupled with development of
organisms you know you might remember
from high school biology
the idea that your dna encodes
information
that is carried over to rna in the
transcription process and then the rna
goes off and makes proteins
that do functional things in your body
that's a true story but it's very far
away from being the entire
story much of your dna does not code for
proteins at all
but it nevertheless serves a purpose in
turning on and off
other dna strands that actually do cause
proteins to be formed
and this makes perfect sense you know
the dna in a skin cell in your body is
the same dna
as in a blood cell or a brain neuron
but of course they develop in very
different ways and this has important
ramifications for
evolution in fact interestingly it's not
just the dna
that can evolve in some sense the uh
chemical environment that a fetus grows
up in in the womb
can affect how its genes are expressed
and that can even be passed on to
subsequent generations
maybe not that far maybe it doesn't last
forever it's a contentious uh area we
talked a little bit about
this with carl zimmer on the podcast a
while ago but in fact we're not going to
mostly talk about that with the other
sean carroll today what we're going to
talk about
is musings on the bigger picture of
evolution that his uh
his cutting edge work with studying
fruit flies and other aspects of the evo
devo story
have led him to really think about what
evolution is how it works and in
particular
the long-running debate about
to what extent evolution is an algorithm
that picks out
the best adaptations for whatever
situation
uh genomic population finds itself in
versus the role of random chance and
what tron wants to do is to emphasize
the role of random chance you know both
adaptation
and randomness are very important but
they have different
aspects that are important in different
ways at different times for different
kinds of things
so this led him to not only under not
only think about randomness in the
course of evolution
but randomness from other things that
impact on the course of evolution like
when an asteroid hits the earth you know
that actually has a very important
impact on evolution even though it has
nothing to do with mutations in our dna
or anything like that
so that's the story we're going to dive
into today we're going to talk about
chance and randomness and unpredictable
events
and the huge role they play both on the
evolution of life
on the large scale and even on
individual lives here on earth
so while i have you here let me remind
you that we have a web page for the
podcast preposterousuniverse.compodcast
i recently wrote a blog post there's a
separate blog
on my website so
preposterousuniverse.com blog
i wrote a blog post about what i look
for when people
suggest potential podcast guests i'm not
limiting myself to guests who only have
the same name as me or anything like
that so
i actually love getting suggestions i
rarely take them just because there's a
limit i get way more suggestions than i
could possibly take but
i do take them sometimes i've gotten
very very good guests
out of people who i would never would
have heard of but someone suggested them
and a lot of people suggest people who i
would never
pick for one reason or another uh and
they're you know
you can read about what those reasons
are in the blog post so check that out
preposterous universe.com
blog if you want to drop some
suggestions who knows i might actually
uh pick somebody in fact as i'm
recording this which is a few days
a few days before the episode actually
airs it's actually published ian
robinson on twitter suggested that i
interview sean b carroll so
ian you're going to think that i did
this because you suggested him but in
fact
we recorded the actual interview a
couple weeks ago anyway
sean b carroll is not only a leading
scientist he's an amazingly good
communicator and writer as you will
learn very quickly in the course of this
interview i
encourage you to check out his books and
with that let's go
[Music]
sean b carroll welcome to the mindscape
podcast hi sean thanks for having me
i'm wondering if i should have just said
sean carroll that would have confused
people even more but i'm i'm very glad
that we're having this
uh chance to talk uh we've known about
each other for a very long time but
and as i always tell people you're the
one with the beard that makes you the
evil
twin by the rules of science fiction
university well and i always say you're
the one that understands the cosmos so
you're the
you're better at math how about that i
think that but you're better at like
like experiments like you have a lab
right you mean you get your hands dirty
yes i do
well i get other people's hands dirty
but i've had i've dirtied my hands over
the years that is true we
yeah we age into an uh a part of our
lives where we get other people's hands
dirty so
but let me i mean you've written a book
let tell people what the title of the
book is so they can rush out to read it
or even you know read it
uh buy it right now as they're listening
you're sure it's in it's in all sorts of
formats if whether you like to read or
listen so it's called a series of
fortunate events
chance and the making of the planet life
and you
that's pretty good so uh but you come
out of this as an evolutionary biologist
who
got interested in the role of chance uh
and
what it plays so i definitely want to
get into that but uh your first book or
at least your first trade book i don't
know if you have i think you have
textbooks and things like that right do
you have do you have a textbook
right yeah so your first trade book was
endless forms most beautiful which is
about the
the extremely hot and sexy topic these
days of evo devo
evolutionary developmental biology so
what was the theme of that
book well that was really you know my
first
sort of mature passion in science that
as i became an independent scientist and
thought about what i wanted to do
i was really driven by you know
curiosity and love for
animal form you know i like butterflies
and snakes
and leopards and all that which i think
a lot of biologists do
and i always wanted to know you know the
hows and whys you know
how did all this diversity evolve and um
the the path to that was long
um for both science and for me
personally because we had to first
sort of crack the science of how any
animal form is built and that's the
that's the arena of developmental
biology
and in the course of doing that started
making discoveries that surprised us
as much as anybody else and that led to
this
term called this field called evo devo
of it's really trying to understand the
evolution of form through the lens of
the making of animal body
okay um so in particular i think that
there are implications in a sentence
like that that are perfectly clear for
you but maybe not for
the audience i mean there's there's a
story to be told about
what genes matter and what they do right
that is a little bit of a shift from the
traditional
paradigm yeah so think about it this way
so the making of an individual form is
is that process of going from egg to
adult and that's development so to get
different kinds of looking adults you
know the imagine the entire
array of the animal kingdom changes have
to happen in that process
so we want to understand what kinds of
changes happen that process of building
animals that give us different
types to do that we had to get into that
inner machinery
which is really the genes that are
involved in building bodies and body
parts and that was really the heyday
starting the 1980s of developmental
biology where we started
cracking sort of the mysteries of how do
animals
sort out you know what's going to be the
front end what's going to be the back
end what's going to be the top the
bottom
right left and it also it all started
with identifying what we call this
genetic toolkit for development a
relatively small number of genes that
are involved in building bodies
yeah i mean it's a fascinating idea
because i think that probably we're
we're most of us are fooled uh by not
knowing a lot of biology and maybe
knowing a lot about or at least thinking
we know about you know
blueprints or something like this we
have the idea that you know
somewhere in our dna there's just a
little road map for all the different
parts of our bodies and you just
have a one-to-one correspondence there
but the reality turns out to be a little
bit more nuanced it is
it's both simpler and more complicated
at the same time so let me try to unpack
that
the simpler part the the great and
thrilling discovery and i was really
close to it so it was
i can really tell you it was thrilling
the expectation
in say the early 1980s before we had a
glimpse of any of these genes was that
really like the building of you know a
human and the building of an octopus or
a
insect had nothing to do with each other
that things were so different
right and that was really kind of the
anatomist's view that you know let's
look at the in
you know the structure of these
creatures and gee they look so different
but what was amazing and this all came
out of studying the fruit fly which has
been
sort of the great workmen of geneticists
for for decades
was that when the first genes were
identified in fruit flies that built
fruit fly bodies we quickly discovered
those very same genes are in
us and in virtually every other animal
in the kingdom and they're
used in very similar ways and they're
even
organized in similar ways in in the dna
and nobody
nobody expected that i've never met
anyone who claimed they expected that
and so that's the simpler part that
there's a common tool kit
then it sort of phrased the next
question well if everybody's got all
this in common
how do you make differences and that's
what i really spent a lot of my research
time on was
working from a common toolkit how do you
build different kinds of animals
yeah so so you're saying that i mean
basically there are some genes that make
legs and among other things and like
how you control what how those genes
turn on and off is depends whether you
get an insect leg or a human leg
that's right and it and where you turn
it on and off also depends whether you
get
six legs as in an insect or eight legs
as in a spider
or a hundred legs as in a millipede so
we quickly sort of got into
you know the the machinery that was
really making the key differences
in the the major differences in the way
animals
um are built and so that that happened
just so much faster than anyone expected
because everyone
thought we were gonna have to work out
sort of the recipe you know for a fly
and a recipe for a mouse and a recipe
for a worm
you know slowly but surely you know and
separately from each other but
really we kind of discovered a passport
to the whole kingdom
yeah and it's it's amazing to me because
it's not only that
different very different species now
have this toolkit
of gene but they've been around you know
i want to say almost forever but at
least uh
for a very very long time in
developmental history evolutionary
history that's that's absolutely true
yeah so at least a half billion years
for these genes to be shared among such
different
animal types as you know sea urchins and
butterflies and
humans birds um they've been around a
half billion years so
pretty much everything we see in the
animal fossil record
you know sort of documents the various
ways these things have been
repurposed and sort of tinkered with
to shape in this incredible variety of
life that we love
well yeah i mean um i'm going to
encourage the audience also to to buy
that book endless form's most beautiful
that you wrote to hear about
the devo side of things but let's dig
into the evolutionary
side of things i mean what are the
implications of this discovery for how
we think about
natural selection or how species evolve
well the
the biggest implication i think of evo
devo is
i'm going to get into mechanism for a
second because i've told you there's
this common tool kit and
kind of the analogy to carpentry or
whatever is somewhat
intentional in that just as a carpenter
can fashion
very different things out of the same
materials these jeans can fashion very
different forms out of pretty much the
same
set of materials how does it do it and
to think about that you got to start
picturing kind of
imagining dna and dna the way it's
organized
our chromosomes are made up of dna and
genes are encoded in segments of dna
and when you think about dna you kind of
and you think about genes if you could
if you could sort of take a quick
snapshot of you know your dna or my dna
those genes would stand out like islands
in sort of a
sea of well we might say junk
things that are not genes things that
don't encode things that
do work in the body so genes that encode
proteins and proteins are the things
that do the work in the body
that's a relatively small part of our
dna there's another part of our dna been
much harder to see much harder to figure
out where it is
and that's the dna that's used like
switches for turning genes on and off
in time and in space and understanding
those switches became
central to understanding the
evolutionary puzzle you just described
because
to build one body you have to
orchestrate the turning on and off of
genes in time and space
and sort of a very elaborate
choreography to build different kinds of
bodies
you have to tinker with those switches
you have to tinker with where they're
turned on how many
places they're turned on or and how and
when and how they're turned off
and so getting at those switches which
was experimentally more difficult
but evolutionarily very rewarding that's
that's one of the
the big insights of evo devo is to
understand that while the genes are very
similar between animals the things
that they encode that make these
proteins that do the work are
very similar among animals nearly
identical between chimpanzees and humans
but how they're used is different and
those differences are wired into the
switches
that are littered throughout our dna and
so that's a huge mechanistic
insight and i think you know pretty
profound biological insight that
you can make lots of different things
from a common tool kit but the action
the evolutionary action is outside of
those genes in the parts of dna that
regulate how they're used
so maybe to put this in context a little
bit you know darwin
comes along with the theory of evolution
by natural selection but he didn't know
about
genes much less dna and then we figured
out that there were genes and
mendel and others although there's a
there's a history of who paid attention
to who
and then we figured out there was dna
and and you know they coded for proteins
etc so
i take it you're going to correct me if
i'm crazy here that there was this
picture that
the things that were being selected on
by the forces of natural selection were
these genes that were coding for protein
and maybe the evo devo
story uh changes that a little bit
because the genes that switch on the
other
genes are equally or more important yeah
and it's the switches themselves so i
think that's that's a true history and i
think
you know part of the way science grows
is as you well document is that
you know sometimes things are just not
within our reach you know let alone our
grasp
and things were outside of darwin's
reach and things were outside the reach
of you know early 20th century
biologists and really
until we clone dna until we
look at individual genes and say okay
here's a gene and in the case of the
fruit fly the sort of the genes that
launched a thousand post-docs
are these genes that when mutated for
example transform the antennae of the
fruit fly into legs
or give the flies a second set of wings
and when you see these
striking you know appearances and you
say you know how can you do that and
it's a single
you've altered a single gene it makes
it's you know you're just too damn
curious you're just like i gotta figure
out what that
what's going on and i was i was one of
those postdocs when i learned about
these
mutations that could change body parts
like that i said well you know what the
heck kind of gene is under there
and that that when we dug into those
things and had the tools finally by the
late 70s early 80s to
analyze the dna that um was the genes
themselves as opposed to just studying
genes
sort of what's called kind of bean bag
genetics of just studying formal
genetics by crossing
um you know one fly to another um that's
when we really could
could get at these these questions and
and when we did
you know the the science you know
flourished in an amazing way
when new yorker magazine asked mark
zuckerberg how he gets his news he said
the one news force he definitely follows
is tech meme for three years and nearly
800 episodes the tech meme
ride home has been silicon valley's
favorite tech news podcast
the tech meme ride home is a daily
podcast only 15 to 20 minutes long
and every day by 5 pm eastern it's all
the latest tech news
but it's more than just headlines you
could get a robot to read your headlines
the tech meme ride home is all the
context around the latest news of the
day
it's all the top stories the top posts
and tweets and conversations about those
stories
as well as behind the scenes analysis
the tech meme ride home
is like tldr too long didn't read as a
service
the folks at tech meme are online all
day reading everything so they can catch
you
up so listen to the one podcast anyone
who's anyone in silicon valley listens
to every day
search your podcast app now for ride
home and subscribe to the tech meme
ride home podcast so
how does this all fit in with the idea
of sort of levels of
selection i mean richard dawkins
famously uh
popularized the phrase the selfish gene
and i'm not sure if i
have the right conception of this but
what i what i took that to mean is that
in some sense
i mean there's the the selfishness of it
okay but
we can argue about that but i think that
a lot of people think that what gets
selected are sort of
traits right like oh you know you want
your neck to be longer so you you
evolve a longer neck but there's no
there's not just
a bunch of switches or dials inside the
organism that says
length of neck and things like that
right there are genes and
you might have genes do or do not
do what you want and a gene that does
what you want might also have other
effects
so how did that change our our picture
of
selection and adaptation yeah let me let
me get to selection adaptation in a
second but
first it had to change our picture of
exactly how how anatomy was encoded in
other words how did you
what was the relationship between
physical anatomy and genetics
and you might have thought for example
that you know maybe we had a gene
for building our pinky and a different
gene for building our thumb
right and maybe a different gene for
making our toes right well we started to
learn through developmental biology that
actually the same genes were involved in
building
every digit you know every toe in fact
they might be involved in building other
parts of the skeleton
so you didn't have anatomy that said you
know
that there was sort of like a
three-dimensional map of the body that
correlated you know sort of beautifully
onto the dna
what you had was these sort of circuits
that were used again and again
in different times throughout the
building of the body
to do very similar operations then you'd
have to say well
how does this evolve because here's the
trick the trick is if you damage one of
these genes the actual
sort of protein coating part of the gene
because it has so many jobs
it's catastrophic right you know it's
what we would call a birth defect in
fact the animal might not be viable at
all
so how do you tinker with the genetic
information in a way
that's viable in fact even novel and
doesn't have this
cost this this dramatic cost and this is
the other
really important discovery of this
regulatory dna these switches
is that these switches act independent
of each other and so you actually have
fine-tuned control of sort of
you know for how long a given gene is
active while you're building a certain
digit
as opposed to really kind of crude
control of just whether that gene
you know exists at all or not yeah so we
first had to change our thinking about
sort of you know where would sort of be
the hot spots of evolution
in dna so the genes the actual protein
protein coding parts of these genes
are very stable and can be
evolutionarily you know
conserved for hundreds of millions of
years but the switches
are very tinkerable alterable in in the
course of evolutionary time
so back to your question about selection
and adaptation it means that
not a huge change in sort of our
classical thought that there's variation
so if you're thinking about evolving a
longer neck or a longer
finger whatever it might be that there's
variation in a population because
there's genetic variation that gives you
slightly different
outputs of say digit length or net neck
length and really it's external
circumstances it's the environment that
creatures live in that generally
determine
whether or not you know a longer neck or
a shorter neck is more favored or a
longer digit or shorter
digit is favored so we're right that
selection occurs really at the level of
traits
because those traits really determine
performance in nature
but you're also the the real basis of
evolution is changes in dna
which are you know down at the molecular
level and those changes which we'll get
to you know those things originally
arise without
any consideration of consequences right
they're arising at random and so really
nature is filtering which mutations can
make it or not
so i don't think evo devos really
overturned our fundamental thinking
about selection and adaptation
i think it's just made us think much
more precisely about
where evolution is taking place at the
genetic level and how that relates to
traits
i mean maybe this is a good place since
i have you here uh
let's broaden our scope a little bit uh
not just to
books you've written but to this broader
question about how to think about
evolution right i mean there
have certainly been claims that sure we
should
say that at this point in the history of
the development of biology
we're no longer darwinian natural
selection people we have a
new synthesis i guess no the news said
this has already happened what
what do we call it now is it is the what
is the attempt to say
that we've moved beyond the traditional
darwinian paradigm
the extended synthesis you know i yeah i
i think it's also our mechanistic
understanding i i think that um some of
my cup there's there's different words
floating out there i'm most sympathetic
to what my
some of my colleagues say sort of the
functional synthesis i think we had
formal descriptions you know for
maybe the first half of the 20th century
of what species are and sort of
understanding how species get made but
until we could crack the genetic code
until we could look under the hood
at how traits evolve you know we had a
fairly
you know let's just say only a a 10 000
foot view
you know of of evolution right and so i
i think it's more about the the richness
and depth of our our under
understanding rather than you know
conceptually have we really
thrown much out that we had before i
don't think so okay so i mean there is
that i mean
i know because i've interacted with
people that emotions get very heated
when we say
you know uh are we just improving
upon the existing paradigm of natural
selection or do we truly have
a different conception now that we know
a lot more about the the multitude of
things that go into these kinds of
considerations well i think there's some
uncontroversial things there for example
you know darwin never imagined things
like
symbiosis or let alone endosymbiosis so
that we know that
some huge things in evolution like
chloroplasts and plants and mitochondria
in us
evolved by the merger of different
creatures you know that's a very
non-darwinian thing but it's
now well established controversial when
first proposed but now very well
established and accepted
so we've certainly found phenomena that
we're not in the darwinian
playbook but you know we can we can
celebrate those things i mean darwin did
not have to be a clairvoyant to all
things
that would ever be discovered in nature
um
now you know in terms of people getting
heated i think
let me this somewhat goes towards the
theme of the current book but let me
let me tell you something that i think
is fair to say historically
darwin's baby really was natural
selection yeah he had to come up with a
way to sort of explain
what kind of process could be at work
that would
shape you know the diversity of the
world and he came up with this analogy
to breeding to domestication or what we
call artificial selection
that he it was brilliant it's how he
started the origin of species he
explained using
pigeon breeds that really what breeders
do with birds or cattle or dogs or
whatever
is very similar to what nature does um
albeit more slowly
and un you know and without you know a
an
intelligence um so that people could get
the idea
that things can change and you know that
was the first thing that he had to
overcome that the thinking at the time
was that species were
immutable that they were divine
creations but from god
and created as they in their current
form and unchanging
so he had a pretty difficult paradigm he
had to dislodge
first he had to get people used to the
idea that things could change
naturally and so natural selection
really was his brainchild
and alfred wallace came up with the very
same idea
um and and that was a huge step forward
he didn't know he explained that there
would be differences in a population and
that natural selection would
you know favor some over others but he
didn't understand the basis of that
variation
if he did we might have a little
different darwinian
theory a little bit different picture so
my personal point of view sean
is that natural selection has dominated
a lot of the discussion and thinking
about evolution
to the point almost where natural
selection sometimes is almost synonymous
with evolution and this i'm gonna say
is missing a big piece of the picture
because the big piece of the picture
both mechanistically
and philosophically is the role of
chance
in generating that variation right it
wasn't of interest to a lot of people
for a long time because there was no way
to get at it if you couldn't
see into the mechanisms of genes well
you just kind of took it as a given
and so natural selection was much more
interesting and natural selection was
you know sort of this dominant idea but
really the idea that
you know order comes from randomness and
randomness is
chance mutation this is a huge idea not
something darwin could have given us he
he pointed at chance a bit in his
writings he he had
some good instincts about it like he had
with many things i mean i'm
i'll you know my aw and you know
regard for darwin will will never be
diminished it's just amazing what his
intellectual contributions are but he
just couldn't get there it was
it was before the time we could get at
it but i i would say i mean
you've had daniel dennett on the show
and you know dennett
really talked about for example you know
natural selection and evolution is this
acid this universal acid that could
dissolve through so many
things speaking philosophically and i'd
actually if
if daniel was here today i'd say i i
think you got to think about chance
because chance is both mechanistically
so important
and it's also philosophically so
important as to why people get so upset
about evolution is because chance chance
is the engine that gives us all this
variation
and um you know without that engine you
you don't have evolution at all
and yet it's fundamentally a random
mechanism so yeah no
i think i'll let you pick through that
and decide where you want to go with it
no
i mean this is great because this is uh
one of the reasons why
i want to get things very very clearly
on the table is i had uh stuart bartlett
on the podcast
a few weeks ago and he is an uh origins
of life researcher
and he mentioned offhandedly that a
certain process you know
didn't seem to fit you know the
traditional darwinian way of thinking
and uh you know i asked him to explain
what he meant by that but actually
after we were done recording he said you
know what
people are going to get confused by that
we should just delete it because
you know i think that there's a
viewpoint out there that the opposite
the the
alternatives are darwin or god right and
i think that what people don't
appreciate is that within the scientific
naturalistic biological way of doing
things uh
there's there's a a whole bunch of
subtlety about you know
how evolution broadly construed actually
works and
like you just said darwin got a lot of
it and he got a lot of it right and he
got some major insights but of course we
keep adding extra stuff
that darwin didn't know about absolutely
and and
you know we should all rejoice in that i
mean you know the science is still
growing or else you know
the last few generations of evolutionary
biologists didn't need to exist
um but you know it's been if anything
you know my good fortune has been to be
living through a new golden era of
evolutionary biology because
our access to the genetic code our
access to being able to
precisely map the relationship between
genetic change
and changes in traits has made it so
powerful to interrogate
all sorts of questions in in
evolutionary biology
so of course i i hope we're discovering
some new and and worthwhile things
but boy i don't find us discarding much
i think this is a growth
exactly an expansion narrative and not
uh you know replacing something and and
if anything
you know when i when i want to elevate
the role of chance when we think about
the evolutionary mechanism
i'm really just saying historically
natural selection has been
the dominant narrative doesn't mean
natural selection is important
of course it's important but don't
overlook chance mutation because
that's the fuel right that makes the
whole evolutionary process run
and when you have a chance process and
we can see just how
chancy that process is now you
understand that there's
nothing in charge a point that i make in
the book
was we now understand we can capture
some of these mutational events now
you know in in a way that you know
thanks to you know great biophysics work
we can capture sort of the moment of
spontaneous mutation
and realizing it you're when we
understand for example that one of the
bases of
of mutation is a subtle chemical shift
just the movement of a proton in a base
which happens as a fundamental matter of
physics you realize that mutation
is a feature not a bug in dna oh yeah
mutation is is something it's due to the
intrinsic characteristics of the
chemicals that make up dna
it's inescapable but now we understand
that you know really down to the level
that i think would satisfy a physicist
and so we're only getting richer and
deeper i don't think we're getting
you know far afield from the darwinian
concept
yeah no i like that way of putting it i
mean uh we haven't overturned much of
what darwin said if anything but we have
we've broadened and enrichened uh the
number of things that are going on which
like you say
what else should we expect this is how
science works right we discover
new things einstein didn't have the last
word on on gravity
after all yeah and you you had neil
schuben on earlier in the year and
neil's a very good buddy of mine and
and and his new book some assembly
required uh
i'll get a i get a commission you know
he makes the great point it's emerged
from paleontology this has been a heyday
for paleontology as well and
oh i mean darwin would just be
salivating uh if he could sit around
with a hundred paleontologists because
this was you know he really had geology
in his bones
and he was so thrilled by
fossils and when he wrote the origin of
species
he proposed that there should be
intermediate forms connecting sort of
one form to another
but there were none in existent in 1859
that we could point
to and these days you know the fossil
record is so much richer
but what have we learned from the fossil
record neil will tell you that
you know it's it's it's a natural
thought for example that you know when
you see feathers on birds
you think they evolve for flight but no
the paleontologists can tell us
nope they evolve for something else
first in the dinosaur lineage
not for flight and if you look sort of
by so many innovations
lungs you'd think oh that's for
breathing on land
nope yeah fish invented them for
buoyancy in the water you know
and and this is the joy of being a
biologist which is you have these
notions which are totally understandable
i think very human notions but then you
have to put them to the test
and the more data you can get the more
evidence you can get it's it's actually
when you overthrow some of your
sort of convenient notions that you feel
like you've really learned something and
paleontologists are learning that almost
everything that we see as a novelty
has some precursor that it wasn't first
for whatever we think it was you know
evolved for and you know and as a
molecular geneticist i can tell you
there's all sorts of you know beautiful
stories in our dna
about you know how this process works
and so um
you know that's that's that's the joy of
it as i said i i think
um there's lots of revelations to happen
because
we still i think think we're looking at
only part of the iceberg
yeah so let's get into the role of
chance which you which you properly
are emphasizing here i mean you
mentioned dan dennett and he he also
likes to say that we should think of
evolution as an
algorithm and i know what he means and
it's true in a sense but i think that a
lot of people in their minds they
conflate algorithm with deterministic
algorithm and uh you can have algorithms
that involve random numbers as well and
that's a crucial role in evolution
that's what you're sort of emphasizing
absolutely and and i think that you know
chance it's just
there was so i i want to acknowledge i
mean there was a really influential book
by a person who had a huge influence on
me i never met him uh jacques manneau
in 1970 called chance and necessity and
this
rocked the philosophical world i mean
this was the best seller
in france i think uh second only to love
story
at the time this was france after all
but i mean it did well in england and
germany and to a degree
it was still highly covered here in the
united states and minnow
coming some for a french tradition and
had one of his friends
when he as he was a scholar was was the
writer albert camus and they shared i
think
some pretty deep conversations um minnow
felt that biology was uncovering some
new
truths some new facts that had not yet
sort of
registered in the philosophical realm
and
so this is 1970 and he wrote chants in
necessity and really pointed out that
this
chance based mechanism in dna had
profound amplification
profound implications for how we think
about ourselves so
you know it got some traction
you know mono passed away six years
later i think
you know the idea of chance is very
prominent in dawkins writings like the
blind watch
watchmaker which is a brilliant book but
i still feel it's kind of slipped out of
common discussions about evolution and
um
and now that we can really see that
chance mechanism and sort of catch it in
the act
what a missed opportunity so i i i sort
of wanted to
lean in and bring sort of our new
understanding of chance
um you know up to date in 2020 and not
just
at the deep molecular level but
including the geological and planetary
level because
we've been startled to discover all
sorts of things that have changed the
direction of life
on earth probably most familiar to to
the audience is
it's the asteroid impact 66 million
years ago and we realized that that
accidents have have had a huge role
in what's happened on this planet if
you're a business that needs to hire
people you know how difficult it can be
to not only find the right people but
sorting through everyone to hire the
right people
indeed.com is the number one job site in
the world
because indeed gets you the best people
fast
unlike other sites indeed gives you full
control and payment flexibility over
your hiring
you only pay for who you need what you
need you can pause your account at any
time
and there are no long-term contracts
plus indeed provides
powerful tools to make your search that
much easier like sponsored jobs
which are shown to be three and a half
times more likely to result in a higher
with 73 percent of online job seekers
visiting indeed each month
indeed is going to get you the important
hire you need just like they have for
over 3 million businesses
right now indeed is offering our
listeners a free 75
credit to boost your job post which
means more quality candidates will see
it
fast try indeed out with a free 75
credit at indeed.com mindscape
this is their best offer available
anywhere so go right now to indeed.com
mindscape terms and conditions apply of
course offer valid through december 31.
well you mentioned jacques and also
albert camus and we
it would be a mistake not to mention
that you wrote a kind of joint biography
of them it's a wonderful story of this
biologist and existentialist philosopher
uh
finding sympathy in each other's ideas
yeah that i got to tell you sean that
was one of the greatest adventures of my
life
you know because it okay yes it took me
to paris frequently but i met i met
incredible people and
what drew me to the story there were
some manoa was an incredible biologist
and all sorts of people i interviewed
who knew him well it's one of the few
people i've ever heard anyone talk about
as being a bona fide genius
and at the same time he was incredibly
as they said in frank in france you know
anger in his time
he was a member of the french resistance
he had some very
um harrowing experiences during world
war ii as did camus
that was clearly a bond between the two
men when they met after the war
so the book is you know it's about their
adventures both
sort of physical in the real world
because they both dealt with
what was going on in society at the time
whether it was defeating the nazis
or exposing stalinism for what it was or
human rights or reproductive rights
whatever it might be
they were they were fully involved and
so i think that made for
for me an exciting story to tell but you
know intellectually
they were clearly on the same wavelength
and camus had influenced
manoa a great deal with his early works
like the myth of sisyphus
but in turn when kemu met mano and mano
had these insights into the workings
of life i think that was very exciting
for for camus so
uh that book and and as i said the
people i met in the in telling that
story
was um you know it was a it was a heck
of a ride so
you can't see me smiling at the moment
but every time i think of my experience
of putting that book together i i was i
was
absolutely on one of the the most
exciting
and and what i mean by thrilling it was
it was every time a new
nugget emerged whether that was in a
letter from an archive
or an anecdote or um or a new interview
of somebody i got to meet who who knew
one or the other um
you know it was just for me a kid from
toledo
uh never imagined i'd be talking to
people uh who who had those life
experiences
well it's so much fun to as a as a sort
of uh
senior researcher let's put it that way
um do a very different
kind of research right you know uh just
not you're not in the lab in this case
uh you're not solving equations you're
doing kind of historical biographical
work and it's
it's just a thrill to you know get that
a different part of your brain being
tickled a little bit right
yeah the rush is very similar um i i've
tried to explain this sometimes to folks
because when people found out when i was
writing the book
and and you know i said i'm writing this
book about jacques and albert camus
you know i mean i'm running a lab i had
some other duties
and and you know you do get the look of
oh yeah you know he's gone off the deep
end
you won't hear from him again many times
um but
you know viscerally the thrill the
thrill is very similar to a great result
in the lab
the storytelling is very similar you're
trying to knit together a narrative and
nothing tells you about holes you know
in a scientific story or holes in a
real world story as when you try to tell
it and realize oh my gosh i can't
connect these two dots
yeah and so for me the process of
researching that book is very much like
working on a scientific problem and that
every time i
i met a gap i had to figure out well is
there any way i could
you know figure out what what what had
happened in this time or
you know who could tell me or what you
know where would the documents be and
when you find those things when you find
the missing links
in the historical record i think it's
the same thrill a paleontologist gets
when they see a fossil for the first
time
and it's a very interesting connection
because the existentialists
you know absolutely wanted to emphasize
the lack of any
overarching purpose or teleology or
reason
for us to be here so you can see why
that would resonate with a
biologist who emphasized the role of
chant uh in the development of life
but also the existentialists wanted to
say you know we can make choices right
like we have some
uh autonomy that lets us guide our lives
how did that fit in or did it fit in
with uh mino's point of view absolutely
and i think the experience of the war
had a huge impact although
camus best sort of formulated his
outlook by about 1942
and published it in the middle of the
war and had to race south from paris
with a manuscript in the trunk of his
car um i think especially coming out of
the second world war which of course for
france was
you know the second traumatic experience
really in a generation
that all these you know nazism
and stalinism and
fascism in all this that you know all
the european isms
let's just say that we're going on or
eurasian isms that
these were all empty right that they
were empty promises of some kind of
utopia
and and the same with religion that that
they were that was a promise of a you
know a better afterlife
right not this life something better was
coming later and i think for people who
had been through the trauma of world war
ii camus was so refreshing because he
was basically saying you know this is
the life we've got
and you know now how do you make the
most of it yeah and i know for lots of
scientists that really resonated camus
was
was very much you know well you know he
is read by everybody but he was
very much embraced by a number of
scientists
and that's because he was kind of
throwing off all this sort of
political mythology or religious
mythology and just saying hey
this is the one life we've got now now
how do you deal with that and
you know this is some of the things you
got into in your your book the big
picture
right you know if you have a naturalist
view of the world
then you have to confront that that this
is it so how do we
live with each other and how do we you
know how do we use our time best and i i
think this is you know this is the
question that the journey in life is all
about
well in a world where accidents happen
and chance
plays a large role i mean maybe you can
say more about uh
what minnows actual um contribution was
there because i guess
my naive version of evolution was that
even as early as darwin we thought that
the the changes from generation to
generation
had a random component uh was that
always there did that
only come in later that came in later i
mean
you can find sort of forensically darwin
is toying with the idea of chance at a
few times
in his work not just origin of species
but later because people had to say yeah
okay
chuck where does this variation come
from and you know he had to kind of
shrug his shoulders and since of course
he was getting resistance for other
reasons
everything he couldn't explain was seen
as a weakness right sure
so it's you have to kind of extract it
there and i think it took a while and it
took sort of the rediscovery of genetics
and then it really took understanding
you know from geneticists of the early
20th century that
you know that mutations arose at random
they could see that if
you know if they were looking for a
white-eyed fly among thousands of flies
they didn't know which one was going to
be born with white eyes it seemed to pop
up at random and
so really we had to get we had to kind
of discover the
randomness of mutation the random
assortment of chromosomes all that sort
of the basic rules of genetics
you know through more thorough science
in the first part of the 20th century
but then when you look at the genetic
code which wasn't you know was not
discovered until the early 60s
and you realize there's a universal
genetic code in every organism
and now you can map how a change in one
you know one base in dna
changes this protein which changes this
trait ah now we're
now you're looking at you know the
fundamental root the fundamental basis
of evolution or the way mono put it you
know the root of all innovation in the
biosphere
yeah and that i think it just took a
while i think
we needed to have dna we needed to have
a genetic code
to say these things with much force and
then i think we needed
other things like evo devo to say them
with even greater force in terms of
understanding thoroughly the connections
between random change at
the atomic level and change at a
organismal level and change at a
population level so now i think we have
that
sort of seamless continuity throughout
all those
all those scales in in life and you know
when we say a word like random
it doesn't mean uh there's no structure
there at all right like
we throw it a six-sided die uh we can
even though it's a random number
the chance that uh the number one comes
up versus numbers two through
six is only one-sixth and so when you
say
that there are mutations in dna that are
random like how well do we understand
the probability distribution of what's
going to happen
at every step in these kinds of process
um it's still a really active field i
think that
when when we talk about random and and
we can say more and i think we can back
it up more let's put it that way
that random means in a couple of ways i
think it's really important and
as you're as you're drilling down here
that we we do get a little more
um disciplined about our use of the word
but it means if you look across dna
mutations are going to occur and there's
an unpredictable nature of that we don't
know
in any individual sperm or individual
egg where the mutations are going to be
but there's going to be 20 in a human
egg or sperm there's going to be 20 or
30 new mutations that weren't in mom or
dad
um they're going to occur you know
spread throughout
three billion base pairs of dna let me
just let me just pause to
to to to say that because that's uh i
didn't i didn't actually catch that
number uh before from
i must have skipped over in your book so
every new baby
comes with uh over a dozen new brand new
mutations
that's is that what we're saying that's
right that's right so each of us is born
with changes in our dna that differ that
that are
different from our parents at the level
of about well probably we're carrying
about 40 or 50 mutations
that weren't there in mom or dad and we
got probably a few more of those from
dad than we did for mom
but yeah there's new mutations in every
generation and this is because
when you copy dna every time you copy
dna
um there's going to be mutations that
are going to happen just
you know it's a 3 billion base pairs of
dna to copy
there are typos and those typos are
really just the fundamental fundamental
matter the physics that i was talking
about
so this is going to go on you know all
the time
the distribution of those mutations
throughout the dna
is and i'm just going to use that
that first approximation argument is
random they're unpredictable
they're spread throughout if you have a
large enough sample you can see
that lots and lots of different places
are collecting mutations
it doesn't mean that every base has
exactly the same
probability of changing but to a first
approximation the distribution of those
mutations are random
and here's the real important thing the
mutations occur
without any let's just call it uh
consideration of their consequences
some of those mutations may be deadly
some of those mutations may be
meaningless
they're going to occur no matter what
it's it's that process of selection and
life is going to sort out what those
muta the fate of those mutations so
those
those mutations arise regardless of
their potential impact
on the organism uh that has to get
sorted out in that individual's life or
in their offspring's life
etc so that's one level of randomness
there's lots of other randomness in that
which chromosomes you inherit from your
mom or dad
involves a random sorting process and
here's a number
that's in the book so if let's you and i
play a little game
especially since we both have the name
sean carroll this might be a fun one to
play
what were the chances so so each of our
moms and
our our dad 23 chromosomes contributed
through the sperm our moms 23
chromosomes contributed
through the eggs so you and i each have
46 chromosomes but now let's think of
our siblings
how many genetically unique siblings
sean could you and i
each have from the same set of parents
yeah it's a it's a big number because i
know how exponentials work but i think
that what
would probably i don't know is um
in a strain of human dna probably many
of the genes are just or many of the
base pairs are just exactly identical in
every bit of human dna and some others
vary so that one i don't know
yeah well we'll first talk about those
combinations so it's over 70 trillion
from one couple
so this means you know the genetic neck
is being shuffled a lot in nature and in
humanity right
yeah so uh and then secondly yeah not
every gene is going to have a variant
you know as you look through dna
but over time there's a lot of variation
that's
there you and i differ by about one base
in every well our irish ancestry might
make us a little more closely related
but
um differ about one base out of a
thousand but you know in
in three billion that's three million
bases that differ between you and i and
between any two
you know unrelated individuals in the
population so there's a lot of variation
out there and that you know all has
occurred
and it continues to occur every
generation
with the occurrence of of new mutation
so the randomness part of this is that
you know there's no there's no intention
here there's
there's no filter mutations happen at
random
and basically life sorts them out and 30
20 or 30 mutations
out of three billion base pairs actually
sounds like a small number but
uh i remember talking with david
baltimore recently and you know viruses
can use rna or combinations of rna and
dna
to carry their genetic information and
they they will you take much more
rapidly
right so in some sense is it too much to
think
that that 20 or 30 per generation is
optimized like that we have the
chemistry that gives us
enough robustness to carry off uh
to send down genetic information through
the generations but also enough
looseness that we can mutate and find
new happy uh features
yeah i think that's a good way to think
about it there there's a concept in
genetics called
the genetic load and mutational load and
the idea is if if we had a very high
mutation rate
you would have too many deleterious
mutations per generation and you'd
obviously have a real problem in terms
of
getting to the next generation yeah too
few mutations and of course nothing
changes at all and your adaptability
is very constrained the mutation rate is
selectable
so in viruses that often carry their own
machinery for replicating
something like hiv the human
immunodeficiency virus
that causes aids that mutation rate is
about 10 000 times higher than what you
and i are talking and this
is uh the selection at work there is
that this is what helps that virus
evade the immune system and this is why
there's no aids vaccine 40 years later
is because the virus is mutating so much
that really the virus
in a in an individual human is pretty
different
after you know a month or two than the
virus that person was originally
infected
yeah so there's a lot of evolution
taking place
um at that uh you know at the individual
virus level
and that's um so if you figure maybe
four or five
orders of magnitude difference across um
genetic things i won't call them living
things because viruses
are not living per se but um yeah so
there's there's even variation in the
mutation rate and you can think that
that
has been tuned by selection in terms of
balancing sort of the mutational load
with
um adaptability and art i need to ask
this are
is it true that we can think of these uh
mutations as
honest to goodness quantum mechanical
fluctuations i i think it's the right
way to think about it
um you're you're talking the if you want
to do chemistry for a second and it's
explained in the book
um bases come in tautomers uh so these
are chemically
uh slightly different forms in this case
these the bases
which i'll just shorthand say ag a c g
and t
which are adenine cytosine guanis uh
guanine and thymine
these bases um the hydrogen
on the larger ring um goes through
transitions um that are you know
it's really just the movement of a
proton on that ring and
thus it's now been measured that that
sort of
shape shift can occurs at a frequency
about
one one at one one thousandth of a
second so
a given base might be in the co what we
call the common um
keto form about 99.9 of the time but 0.1
percent of the time
it's in the enol form and if that is the
form it's in when the copying machinery
passes by the wrong base can be inserted
and now you've got a mutation now
there's ways because also that base
will flip back there's then ways for the
cellular machinery to recognize that
mismatch and excise it
so there's proofing mechanisms that
improve the
fidelity of copying dna by several
orders of magnitude so there are
correction mechanisms we have but
nonetheless
a small percentage um slip through but
you're absolutely right this is like
this is a quantum mechanical phenomenon
and i think uh
um you know one of the scientists i i
remember using the term
a quantum flip that might be a word that
a biologist or biophysicist use as a
as a quantum flip and it's an inherent
nature of the of the bases that that
endowed dna with its
with its properties well a famous
thought experiment in biology is if we
could play the tape
backwards right if we could start back
with whatever initial conditions life
had
and let everyone go how similar would it
be and now
uh it seems that i'm going to say that
if you believe in the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
there will be a different world where
every different set of mutations came
true and somewhere out there all the
different possibilities have been tried
well it's a great thought experiment
i think you uh and a sampling of
different biologists they'll probably
lean to one way or the other there are
some folks that see the tape as
replaying more accurately you know more
um uh you know replaying itself more
accurate more i want to try to say maybe
with more fidelity repeating itself
maybe evolution repeating itself more
um and others seeing less so i probably
tend towards the less so partly because
i also think you have to
deal with all the external sort of
physical circumstances of the world
and that you know tectonics and
asteroid impacts and all sorts of other
things have um
it you know have have wreaked havoc on
the on the
process of the evolution of life and so
um
yeah i think that thought experiment for
me is you you'd get a different world
and
i don't know if we get dinosaurs and
humans you know that many times
yeah no i mean i think that uh there's a
interplay going on here between the
randomness of the generation of the
mutations
and then they're selected for right this
is what darwin actually
uh emphasized the fact so i guess there
are by every biologist
you know every card carrying modern
biologist will admit that there's
randomness in the mutation
but i guess some would argue that when
those mutations
come out as organism some will
inevitably thrive and some will not and
that's why we will see
more less similar behavior if we did run
the tape backward again
yeah look this and that's the phenomenon
of convergence and you might say
you know this this argument was made
especially famous by stephen j gould in
his book
wonderful life encountered by simon
conway morris in life's crucible
to paleontologists um and you know i
think
the truth is is fun to explain not the
truth i can't say the truth
both polls are fun to explore because
there's no doubt that evolution
repeats itself and when we find very
similar circumstances
you know if you find animals living say
in a um
in a dark habitat in caves no doubt you
will see the same independent mutation
selected for
again and again if you find things
living in deep water you'll find some of
the same things selected for
again and again um so there are external
circumstances
external conditions that will
essentially create the same selective
regime
and you can think that if you have a
large enough population of whatever you
want
you know fish mice whatever you want to
think about if you have larger
population you will basically this
random mutation mechanism will sample
most of the possible mutations you know
in the dna of that organism
and so uh it may happen upon the same
solution repeatedly and we
this has been well documented by sort of
simple to study
organisms like viruses but even out
there as i said you know mice in the
deserts of the american southwest
living on you know lava outcrops they
repeatedly do the same sort of
evolutionary tricks
bacteria living in our guts exposed to
antibiotics
keep coming up with same mutations so we
can see evolution repeat itself but you
just have to kind of drill down a little
bit to say well
if i've really presented very similar
circumstances
to a highly to a large population of
individuals with a pretty significant
pool of mutations to draw from
you you will draw the same lucky card
repeatedly but when you start
way back you know a billion or two
billion years ago when life is
unicellular
and you say okay i'm just gonna run this
whole thing again there are so
many factors that enter the um course of
life
that it's difficult for me to think that
that you're gonna get
t-rex and neanderthals out of that uh
again and again yeah that does make
sense to me but i think
also and you have alluded to this but
let's let's highlight it a little bit
um you know most mutations in
the world like that we live in now where
species are fairly mature and have found
their niches and so forth
most mutations are going to be bad right
like we we've kind of optimized to some
extent and the chances of getting a
really good
mutation that we hadn't already tried
are relatively small but
at a time like 66 million years ago when
an asteroid just hit
and wiped out a lot there were a whole
bunch of unoccupied niches and you know
the chance to let your experimentation
run wild was much greater well i think
intuitively that's
again that's a very interesting question
and a very interesting arena to explore
now let me take the first part where you
said you know where things sort of
speak these mature and in stable
habitats
will morph mutations be deleterious well
actually most mutations aren't
deleterious anyway because they just
land in parts of dna that don't matter
but if you land in a part of the dna
that matters
what you're i think intuitively right
about is and this is probably best
illustrated by things like
enzymes so enzymes that do the work in
the body that convert one chemical to a
different chemical form
a lot of these enzymes have been around
for hundreds of millions
sometimes more than you know a billion
years they do
show properties of being optimized so
that
it's very hard to make like a more
efficient
enzyme to say detoxify alcohol okay
because organisms have had a long time
to play with that substance and they've
probably happened upon the best solution
that's too bad now if an organism finds
itself in a high alcohol environment
what it does is instead of evolving an
enzyme that is more proficient
at converting that alcohol it makes more
of that enzyme and it makes more of that
enzyme through mutations
that enable it to make more of that
enzyme so there's still adaptive
mutations to be had
but qualitatively they're a little
different they're not so much about
changing the properties of an of a very
ancient enzyme
they're about changing how much you make
in a given circumstance
so i think you're intuitively right
there uh in terms of sort of things
being
well tuned on the other hand and there
was the second part of your question
which i've now forgotten because i
had to i had to give my alcohol story i
know
you made me sad to think that there's
not some mutation waiting out there to
be discovered that will make us
able to drink a lot more good wine and
scotch but that's okay you know
we have to live with the the constraints
of the laws of physics but the other
point was
we have these accidents of history that
have nothing to do with biology like the
asteroid hitting the earth that sort of
reset a lot of the environments and then
then maybe
the experimentation has a little bit
more room to play in great yeah thanks
sorry
um yeah i think that's also a very
constructive way to think about things
and that when
new opportunities present themselves and
certainly after the asteroid impact with
three quarters of plant and animal
species
killed off um you know the ocean was a
very different habitat post asteroid the
land was a very different place
um you know competition's different and
you think about sort of
for lack of a better word organisms
establishing a beachhead well in that
competition there might be a lot more
room for
variants and for things that might have
had a really tough time in a more
in a well-populated you know forest um
or in a more densely populated ocean
so the the regime the competitive regime
changes
a real straightforward example and i
love this story this was just published
last year
um the asteroid story is it's a gift
that keeps on giving is what i would say
sean
because um while we probably all heard
the outlines of it
um and and relived in one way cinematic
or or otherwise
that asteroid impact um what happened
after
that has been harder for paleontologists
to get at and that's just has to do with
few exposures on the surface of the
earth of that
critical say first million years after
the asteroid impact
particularly exposures on land but uh
scientists at the denver museum of
science and nature
tyler leeson and ian miller struck
paleontological gold just outside of
denver
a few years ago and it was published in
science last year and actually we made
it into the film into a film called the
rise of the mammals
when they discovered a treasure trove of
remarkably preserved
extraordinarily well preserved mammals
spanning that first million years of
recovery on earth
and what you see among those mammals are
that mammals
got much bigger very quickly than they
ever did before
in earth's history so mammals were have
been around for probably 100 million
years
coexisting alongside dinosaurs but
dinosaurs were the
you know they were the big they were the
big land animals on the planet
well dinosaurs are killed off they're
very vulnerable to the collapse of the
food chain
some small mammals survive which
probably were not more than a pound or
two in body size
and then they take off and within a few
hundred thousand years you're seeing a
40 or 50 fold increase in maximum body
size among the mammals
so quite clearly take away the big you
know
i'd say i'm not going to say the bullies
that's putting characteristics to
dinosaurs i don't really want to put on
them but that dominant animal
that was really keeping mammals in a in
a much smaller niche
take away those dinosaurs and the
mammals exploded and so there was no
room there were no place for those
mutations that would make mammal bodies
bigger
during the dinosaur era but take away
the dinosaurs and now those mutations
um allowed us allowed mammals to explore
all sorts of
body forms so i think we have good
understanding that
um you know a big disruption like that
uh ecological opportunity
um one of my favorite paleontologists
there are many but andy knowlt
at harvard has framed it something along
the lines of sort of when when
when you know genetic potential meets
ecological opportunity
and these big upheavals on the surface
of the earth present ecological
opportunity
and then all that genetic potential um
can flower and that's that's what i
think we see with the rise of the
mammals i think that's what we see in
the cambrian explosion which is
following another mass extinction the
very famous cambrian explosion probably
the easiest explanation for it
is the opening of ecological opportunity
you know i often talk about entropy and
friction
and dissipation and these are concepts
that are important not only
for cosmology or for living organisms
but also for small businesses
how do you like that segway there pretty
good huh aslo
is a new way of doing banking online for
small businesses that removes all the
friction
aslo offers free business checking
accounts with invoicing
bill pay money transfers no minimum
balances
and no fees unlike other banking options
as low is painless there's no ridiculous
phone system that feels designed to
waste your time
with aslo you just go to a z azlo.com
and apply
in as little as 10 minutes there's no
waiting to use the account
with aslo's free instant funding feature
you can deposit up to a thousand dollars
and access it instantly
so sign up right now with no minimum
deposit at aslo.com
mindscape and get a free copy of aslo's
small business starter guide
spelled azlo.com
mindscape sign up with a free small
business starter guide
no minimum deposit aslo.com mindscape
and so this it does you know when you
sort of think of it in those terms
um the asteroid impact being a very
obvious one you know the role of chance
comes to the fore right not just the
mutations in our genes but like
the fact that our environment is
changing in unpredictable ways
the other point you make in the book is
that even within individual
lifetime uh there are things happening
in our bodies that are a little bit
random and unpredictable that end up
playing a huge role
in the lives we leave yeah this is this
is the unfortunate series of events
you're referring to cancer for example
for example yeah i mean uh i i presume
that
a whole bunch of aging and uh other
disease kind of things have similar
features but cancer is the obvious one
the big one
cancer is the obvious one because you
know it shows up in the clinic and then
we study it and we really understand
cancer is a genetic disease so
yeah so that that process of random
mutation which
is is the source of you know all that
beauty and diversity and complexity in
the biosphere
and all of human diversity you know
which we celebrate
well but it is a fact of life that when
we copy dna mistakes get made
and some of those mistakes if they land
in certain places in the genome in
certain genes
can alter the properties of those cells
and if those cells
acquire a growth advantage relative to
their neighbors
and particularly if more mutations hit
that might either
enhance that growth advantage or shield
those cells for example from the immune
system
well then now you have the beginnings of
of cancer so
in the book i'm we're just trying to
make people to appreciate that
you know this phenomenon of of random
mutation
impacts lots of things um you know i
think there's some things that are
more joyful and i think i say when i get
into the cancer chapter you know oh boy
i'm not sure everybody was going to be
too enthusiastic about reading this but
you know it's going to affect a very
sick you know all of us it's going to
affect our families and individually
it's going to probably affect you know
half of us at some point in our life so
understanding that cancer is a genetic
phenomenon
brought on by random mutations but that
we can do something
about the probability of those mutations
so cigarette smoke contains mutagens
so um we can decrease our chances of
mutations that hit our lung cells by
either not smoking and not
inhaling second-hand smoke or i'm going
to go golfing later this afternoon
and as a lightly pigmented irishman
i have to put on my sunscreen oh yeah
i'm gambling with the mutations in my
skin cells
so um you know that knowledge of
cancer being a genetic phenomenon is is
also power and
you know in the last 20 years we've
developed a lot of
countermeasures to to deal with the
mutations that arise in our
uh in our body in the course of our
lifetime but i i did
you know we come into this world an
accident and many of us are going to
exit
you know due to one of these accidents
well i think it's part of facing up to
the random nature of life and there's a
truism that human beings are not very
good at
conceptualizing randomness i did a whole
podcast with maria konokova
about poker and and you know living in
in conditions of uncertainty but one of
my favorite examples i think i've
mentioned this in the podcast before but
it's my podcast no one's going to stop
me from mentioning it again is when you
talk about
life expectancy there's a million
different websites you can go on to and
calculate your life expectancy and they
always give you a number right
like you'll probably live to be 90. and
i think that people conceptualize that
as i'm gonna probably live to 90 and
then die but i did find
one website that actually also and i've
lost it now and it kills me because i
can't find it again but
it actually took the probability right
so rather than just saying
uh your expected value is 90. you know
it knew what
the tails were and it would randomly
generate a number from that distribution
you can click the button again and again
and i think we don't appreciate how
broad
that distribution is like i got plenty
of times when i was dying before the age
of 60. and plenty of times when i lived
to be over a hundred and
that knowing that you're going to live
to abroad 90 on average is
interesting but much less relevant than
the fact that you could die within years
that's
absolutely possible absolutely and this
you know this this should be the realm
of psychology and i think we can all
benefit from the insights of
psychologists because of course we're
playing all sorts of games with
ourselves to you know
deny that right there's a lot of
cognitive dissonance around death
everyone's struggling to figure out well
how do we use the time we have you know
in that unknown amount of time
one of my dear friends from childhood
died young
in his 40s and i sort of feared in the
religious service
you know what do you say about somebody
who dies young you know and everyone's
crushed right everyone's absolutely
crushed
sure and the minister talked about life
being a gift
nice but a gift of of you know unknown
quantity
unknown unknowable what quantity you get
so think about
how you're going to spend it and i i
found that to be a very secularly
friendly
eulogy um and and and you know
thoughtful
and um you know you've dealt you dealt
with this
in in your writings you know camus dealt
with this
so many people have dealt with this yet
i think you know what you're getting at
is that
we have lots of games we play with
ourselves to sort of
deny our own death and to just put it
out of our minds
it's sort of understandable but and if
you and and then
you can imagine all the you know how
many movie plots have there been about
people knowing they're going to die the
next day right or if they don't do this
they're going to die at a certain time
or an asteroid is coming and we only
have so much time etc and how people
behave
but we've got to figure out what to do
when we don't know how much time we've
got left
yes and you know we all look for some
wisdom
anywhere we can you know into that i i
by the way and i mentioned this in the
book
um i looked to comedians that's that's
where i get my
that's where i get my psychology and
philosophy from so
well i mean i think that you you very um
effectively uh convey this idea in the
book and this is one of the reasons why
it's a great book worth reading is that
not only do you do biology and so forth
but
you're not afraid to talk about the
ramifications of these ideas for how we
live
our lives and how we think about our
lives and you know they're
among the things that the human brain is
not good at among
probability being one of them but
another one is just accepting
that some things happened without a
reason right that
uh we always tend to say well oh if this
happened
why did that happen and i'm gonna find
the reason i'm gonna fix it or whatever
and uh you know i think i forget who it
was it might have been stephen colbert
you know considering uh your idea that
it's comedians who are the wisest here
but he says
whenever anyone tells him everything
happens for a reason he uh
pushes them down the stairs and then he
says i bet you can understand the reason
why that just happened
but a lot of things don't and it's very
hard to
craft a vision of life that accepts
that things happen without explicit
right
well there it is sean i think there it
is which is why we have
you know so much of the mythology that
we have it's understandable i mean
people are trying to think you know why
why would we think about the afterlife
well it's a very pleasant and
comfortable you know comforting thought
and
and wow you can create so much story
around all that
it's very hard difficult very difficult
to deal with
you know the finite nature of life i
mean life is great
but ricky gervais and i quote it in the
book you know he just says look this is
a holiday we get we we didn't exist for
you know 14 and a half billion years and
now we exist and we get 80 or 90 years
if we're lucky
yeah um you just make the most of it now
there might be a
and then you got to think about okay
what does make the most of it mean but
at least it's
i think it's healthy psychologically i
think it's also
really constructive in terms of how you
choose to spend your days is to say
look you know accept that this is it and
i think that kind of puts a premium on
your time
i also think it makes you put a premium
on other people's lives and their time
there's actually some
compassion and empathy that comes for
that that might surprise people who are
you know believers and who think that
you know religiosity is important that's
a that's you know essential to a sort of
a moral life
but no i i think when you realize that
everybody else also is constrained to
one life that
it it might make you a more empathic and
compassionate human being it's possible
it is it is and i i don't claim to have
fully figured it out myself do
have you heard about the discourse in
philosophy circles around
moral luck the idea of moral luckiness
no i don't know this
i mean the point that's fun it is it is
fun because uh you know
in the real world you know you you have
a few too many drinks and you hop in
your car and you try to drive home right
and that's against the law and you can
be pulled over and and punished for that
but if you happen to run over someone
once you pass through a red light
because you were drunk driving
uh just by chance the punishment is
enormously greater
than if you just drove home while
inebriated even though your actions were
the same
the punishment is not because it depends
on completely random things
and so how do we deal with that and you
might say well okay just give the same
punishment to everyone who does exactly
the same things but that's it's
that's hard to do it's certainly not
what we actually do in life like coming
to terms with this is
is even harder in real life than it
sounds at first glance i think yeah
no but i i think these are these are
really exciting
discussions to have and in some ways
they're you know they're
unfortunately probably hadn't too narrow
a circle
right that i think if we were not so
dominated by
religious ideas and i don't mean to i
don't mean to dis religion i
i grew up and i was i was educated thank
goodness i was educated for example in a
catholic high school that if that had
not existed i don't think we'd be having
that conference this conversation today
but i do think that to dominate the idea
that there is you know a supernatural
supreme being overlooking each of our
lives
you know that sort of inhibits
exploration of other ideas that
might actually be really constructive
for how we we live our lives and
um so you know there's i i i just hope
that you know as generations pass that
there's just more exploration of
moral luck and you know the meaning of
life without an afterlife well
uh to borrow a phrase you are preaching
to the converted
when you say that but i mean maybe maybe
to
to close up here uh i think it's been a
great conversation and you know we've
at least reminded people about the
important or the fact that there's a lot
about what's going to happen in our
lives that is not either purposeful or
predictable
but camus if we can conjure him up here
might have said
that you know we can bring some meaning
to our lives by taking actions
so you do that among other things
besides being a biologist and a writer
uh you produce movies and i just want to
give you a chance to
to explain to the audience out here why
in the world
when you clearly have enough on your
plate you've decided to
uh become a movie producer um stories
so same reason for writing books same
reason for you and i having this
conversation you know
we're telling stories um but film is
such a powerful vehicle for stories and
especially for science films sort of
taking people on an adventure and
immersing them in experience that they
might not otherwise have
and um and i'm also i had some
interesting early experiences with
filmmakers and i was really intrigued by
their craft because i've seen filmmakers
you know concoct you know scenes out of
their imagination
that you know i just couldn't possibly
imagine
you know how they did that um and and so
you know i'm
i'm comfortable well not comfortable but
let's put it this way i you know i try
to write stories on paper
when i've seen them translated to film
there's just
other dimensions that open up and also
film you know it
travels very well around the world and
of course many of us seek out stories in
film form so
you know the brass tacks truth for two
writers like you and i is that
a hundred or a thousand times more
people will see the film version than
read our books
sure right so there was a little bit of
pragmatism but it's also the excitement
of telling stories and
in other forms and when it goes well um
that it's also a very collaborative
craft and you know the combination of
visual imagery
and music and all this can be you know
just such a powerful memorable
experience and so
i've had the opportunity through the
position i have now is the head of a
documentary studio
inside of philanthropy um you know to
work with lots of filmmakers and to
support the work of lots of filmmakers
and
i think science stories you know we we
need more of them out there in the world
and it was another big motivation is
that
is to help science with its place in our
culture
by telling more science stories and
trying to reach some audiences that
would not
otherwise you know tune in for a story
about science yeah i mean
uh tell me what you think but to me if
you can find
an activity that on the one hand
is just a lot of fun to do but on the
other hand
also provide some good for the world
then you'll find a way
to get involved with that and that
sounds like what you've done yeah it's
thanks sean it's not that different
honestly than like teaching
i mean it's it's certainly not as it's
not you know as pedantic as teaching
it's just
you're sharing stories with the world in
a form like you know
science has to compete with every other
form of story in our world right and
people voluntarily
and you know choose to listen or pay
attention or not so science
has to realize that we live in a you
know we're a storytelling animal in a
storytelling world
we have to tell our stories and we have
to move people you know i think the
the biggest you know sort of shortcoming
i find among scientists is that we you
know we think that
if people only knew what we knew you
know only knew what was going on in our
heads
the world would be fine you know maybe
that's true
but you got to motivate people to want
to know a little bit more about what we
know and you and you have to bring it in
a form that is
engaging and inspiring and emotional you
know we're
very much you know sort of cerebral
beings as scientists but
but you know we are we're an emotional
species and i think
it's that combination of storytelling
and visuals and music and things like
that
that can arouse that and be a much more
intense experience for people than dare
i say
reading a book pressing company accepted
of course when it comes to
uh reading the books but oh yeah
absolutely of course but books are i'll
tell you this as a
having made a lot of films books are a
great place to start because exactly
writers have have often fleshed out a
lot of story threads that are great
places to
for filmmakers to to pick up so it's a
it's a necessary process it's
also books are generally a lot more uh a
lot deeper and broader than films are
films have to
sort of keep up their pace and cannot
wander into some of the dimensions that
that a book can so they're
they're they're different media they
they each serve their important purposes
but i am i am acknowledging that uh
film might just be a little more popular
[Laughter]
it's possible that it does i mean you
know but there's a there's an
important role for a complex ecosystem
of
ways of communicating and one thing i've
discovered is that having uh the ability
to listen to someone's voice provides
people a connection with them they
wouldn't otherwise have which is why
it's so great to have people like you
here on the podcast so sean carroll
thanks very much for appearing on the
mindscape podcast
thanks john it's a lot of fun
[Music]
you